no I don't think the euro is a failed
experiment yet they have a lot of
challenges ahead clearly they were
trying to back themselves into a common
currency area by creating a common
currency and from a u.s. perspective
that seems like sort of doing everything
backwards because we're used to thinking
about the hundred years we spent
building the common market and good
services and corporate control coming
out of the Commerce Clause here in the
United States and that whole evolution
leading up to the creation of monetary
union and continent-wide physical
stabilizers no Sarah doing it backwards
they're trying to begin with a common
currency and then reverse engineering
into a common monetary policy common
banking system and continent-wide fiscal
stabilizers so they may yet pull it off
but it remains to be seen they made a
lot of progress this summer they brought
in risks premium quite a bit with
draghi's courageous statement that he
would stand behind the euro and then
they've started to break the problem
down into manageable pieces so 100
billion euros for the Spanish banking
system is different from banking Union
is different from fiscal Union is
different from the ECB's operation and
as the market came to see all those
different components more clearly we
took a lot of risk premium out still a
lot of work to do to make sure that they
can hold the Euro together and that it
doesn't spin out through a lack of
competitiveness on a part of a lot of
countries but they can pull it off but
they might not it's down to execution
risk now
you